was the 33 points he had monday against
the los angeles lakers
and utah hasn't necessarily shot the
basketball
great in this restart nice move and
reversed there by murray
daly vanishing and free-to-play games
here comes murray with a nice clutch
crew move for two
high character and great ex court
experience
miaoni has checked in for
utah and that's donovan mitchell who
connects once again
here's royce o'neil back in the game
go bear out to mitchell three good
puts it through
and here comes murray look at all that
shooting on the floor
and murray again hits murray has come
off in his first game in the restart
a two of seven in the second half from
the jazz from deep where there was 12 of
27
in the first his possession has to have
joker written all over it murray has got
10
points 10 rebounds he scoops up his 12th
point
you'll get murray
murray fade away for the lead good has
been very very
oh that is special wow that is
absolutely special if you knock down the
three and make it a free-throw
game you cannot advance the ball as
mitchell
gets the three what a shot by donovan
mitchell one point
game seven point one seconds and a quick
foul by the all-star
donovan mitchell and turning the other
way too kevin
that was amazing donovan mitchell
works by the defense takes it down got
the way up and puts it through
point nine to play game is tied at 105.
mitchell making a move in a congested
lane got it counted foul
taliban mitchell continues to make big
baskets for the jazz
tie game overtime mitchell trying to get
the lead
got it got it 3.4
mitchell's done it again
murray trying to get free and another
fade away
that'll drop i mean royce o'neal is all
over him
a little step back touched every inch
look at this well how many step backs is
murray going to knock
down in this